Oh
[Music]
you guys here to check in yes you see
what they did to the rooms today it's
amazing I've created a delicious new
menu perfect for this region and my team
have been training the staff non-stop to
prepare them for a successful relaunch
tonight dinner menu I've invited the
locals back and a local food critic so
the lodge can rebuild these important
relationships and get their reputation
back on track everybody just for a
second our critic is sitting watching
paying attention to everything that's
going on thank you hello we just wanted
to welcome you all to the lodge and I
hope you're enjoying the evening and we
appreciate y'all coming in and Chyna
Seguin and loved to have you back can't
beat the setting of course and from now
on our foods gonna match all those
things so hope you're having a great
time very nice to have everybody back
okay welcome have a great time
1/4 right up here what are you doing
what are you doing right now is going 3
ribeye and then your do short rib and we
send the appetizers Gina Gina come here
come here
you're not even helping yourself not
talking to me are you just going to one
I'm gonna force you to talk Gina are you
okay I'm okay I promise okay good again
ask there you can serve the soup all
right what do please
absolutely okay suit boiling we send the
soup with one nice kale salad so next up
arts dress me a kale salad okay why
can't he make the salads never ask me
that's difficult you can't work on your
own I worked on my own many puns chef
Gina Gina come here come here
are you listening oh you're giving up
well I've told you cannot work on your
own you just show I work on my own all
the time
is it best you go now you can't work on
your own you got to sink this place get
a grip okay it's not difficult
next ticket
yeah fYI and that's not Jeana struggling
yeah Kurt stepped up out stepped up but
with a menu that easy if you mind not in
that you've got no chance
kale salad in the window table 26 seat
one is that for the critic
three season I did salt pepper
and art take over please Gina take a
step back arts Jews on the deserts let's
go okay I got chicken in the oven so
with those three apple crisp in the
other well you forgot they are in the
oven chef yeah Donny reheated is uh I
expect you to nail that's your table you
know that nice and gently
yes sir off you go roasted chicken with
the crisp skin how we can't do a scoop
of ice cream no answer
we can't do a scoop of ice cream it's
cold in the middle stop
I want you to take your apron off